what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and oh my god what an
amazing chapter of dragon ball super we
have to discuss today
this is why i love super so make sure to
stay tuned for this one if you do
enjoy seeing these dragon ball super
reviews i want to keep them coming
channel the god of destruction within
and smash that like button until it's
blue if you haven't make this the video
you subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball super videos
also while you wait for the next dragon
ball super chapter to drop feel free to
check out my dragonball virgin podcast
where i watch the entire dragon ball
series with my friend who's never
watched anime before and we discuss it
we are actually already at the morrow
arc so we'll be here with granola
very soon link to the podcast is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all
this chapter title is simple but very
hyped nonetheless it's called vegeta vs
granola
and we'll finally get to see vegeta step
up and see if he can do better than goku
i predicted he would do better because
otherwise having this battle second
rather than first would be pretty
pointless so let's see what happens
we get a quick page of the residents of
the planet and we see that they are
being affected by the fighting which is
creating explosions and tremors we then
jump to vegeta and it's funny how
granola still thinks that
frieza is their boss and clearly thinks
that frieza is stronger
since his whole clone thing against goku
was to save his strength for frieza
we get a pretty hilarious moment where
vegeta explains that he parted ways with
frieza long ago but granola interprets
it as one of those i'll betray my boss
if it means
i get to live kind of moments and calls
vegeta and saiyans pathetic
wow this dude knows exactly what to say
to upset vegeta vegeta manages to
maintain his cool
pretty well all things considering and
just tells granola to think what he
wants and that vegeta was just a child
when the saiyans invaded this planet
granola then proceeds to seem less like
a good-ish
guy and more like a villain when he says
i will have my revenge against
all saiyans he's generalizing and
putting all saiyans into the same boat
which is obviously
not cool would he kill pan too just
because she's a saiyan
i look forward to seeing how his
character progression goes from here but
right now despite starting out as a
good-ish
antagonist he's become pretty villainous
i love vegeta though and how he just
smiles at hearing this and takes it as a
sign that he doesn't need to hold back
he also pours salt on the wound when he
tells granola to prepare to perish along
with his people's history so between
vegeta and granola this has pretty much
become a battle of the saiyan race
versus the
serialian race then the much anticipated
fight begins
we knew that although vegeta was trained
with beerus it still felt like he was
behind goku
and his mastered ultra instinct form so
now we can finally see what the
strongest version of vegeta we've seen
so far has to offer and whether he's
closed the gap between him and goku
against goku granola finished him and
his mastered ultra instinct form
effortlessly after he stopped using a
clone to battle now it can be argued to
what extent
exactly was goku caught off guard by the
attack and all that
but still he got pretty wrecked from the
looks of it vegeta got the benefit of
seeing and analyzing granola's previous
fight
so he did have an advantage compared to
goku there but unless he has the
strength to back it up some extra
knowledge won't necessarily make that
big of a difference
immediately we see that vegeta is
lasting longer than goku did against
granola part of this could just be the
fact that granola is showing off and
toying with him in the beginning but
it's nonetheless a joy to watch
and you gotta give credit to vegeta for
taking multiple blows from granola
without going down
or at least without staying down for the
first portion of the fight granola is
taking the lead while vegeta is focused
on surviving and even swimming at one
point
we get to see a cool move by granola
where he gets a sort of sniper assist
for his energy blast which is cool to
see
i like that dragon ball super is getting
more creative with the energy blasts
like this
notably vegeta manages to actually
survive this attack the granola surprise
he can't help but admit that and to
quote him you people
and quote are stronger than he expected
again keep in mind goku was taken down
after one hit of non-clone granola
vegeta is still standing after many hits
part of it is him being better at having
his guard up compared to goku but still
vegeta is doing pretty great already
against the strongest fighter in the
universe and
i love to see it and then we get a scene
i think we really needed granola
believes that he'll remain the strongest
in the universe no matter what so
struggle is pointless
and then vegeta gives him a reality
check just because granola is stronger
at the moment it doesn't mean he'll
remain the strongest and props to vegeta
even though he's being outmatched
currently
he still smiles and is confident that
he'll win and even says as much
this is the vegeta i love to see rather
than the one who gets overly scared by
broly in the non-canon movie
or beerus in battle of gods vegeta even
teases granola calling him mr
strongest i absolutely love how granola
is winning the physical fight and yet
vegeta is the one smiling and granola is
the one frowning
clearly upset goku finally wakes up and
his injury
is still giving him a lot of pain he
sees vegeta and granola fighting imogia
seems to more or less be keeping up with
granola and he's clearly winning the
mental game
he even causes granola to blow up some
of the city's remains
and then he pours salt on the wound
again by saying and i quote you're fine
blowing up what's left of the city
full of all those precious memories end
quote it's great how vegeta can be a
good guy and yet also be
so good at smack talk like this granola
calls him a dead man and he's been mad
at vegeta for a while now so in theory
if he could have finished him off by now
he would have
vegeta even realizes that granola has
just recently gained his power because
he sees that he's majorly lacking in the
battle experience to back it up
this is an important detail because i'm
sure a lot of us felt like it was
cheap to just wish you're the strongest
while we've been following characters
who've been training since the beginning
to get to their own level of strength
but there are these little parts in the
story that make it feel a bit less cheap
like the fact that you gotta pay with
your lifespan
like the fact that just because you are
currently strongest doesn't mean you'll
remain the strongest and now as vegeta
is pointing out the fact that dragon
granted strength doesn't completely make
up for a lack of battle experience
we need these moments or else we kind of
feel cheated that someone could surpass
goku and vegeta so easily
after all of their years of brutal
training and hard work
granola even says that there's no need
for him to train
and in his defense he does get some good
hits on vegeta
but vegeta is just so awesome that he
keeps coming and even lands a shoulder
attack that seriously upsets granola why
is granola so upset by this one attack
unlike vegeta he's probably not even
used to feeling the pain of such attacks
so his reaction is way over the top
compared to vegeta's because vegeta has
experienced
countless beatings in his life against
powerful opponents
and then we get even more vegeta
epicness while granola is saying that
he's the strongest and so he's
guaranteed to win vegeta begs to differ
vegeta says and i quote that's the great
thing about a battle the outcome is
never quite set in stone it's exactly
what i love about fighting end quote
you can see the pure pleasure vegeta
takes in the battle and the respect he
has for it
something that's completely lacking in
granola who doesn't fight for the love
of it but as a means to an end for
revenge
finally vegeta tells granola that
strongest second strongest rankings are
well and good
but they only reflect a moment in time
once that moment has passed it's nothing
but history
even if granola was way in the lead at
the beginning of the fight vegeta has
already gotten way
stronger over the course of the fight so
he's way stronger than he was a few
minutes ago
the implication is that it's only a
matter of time before he edges ahead of
granola
soon to be yesterday's strongest fighter
granola takes all this talk as a
reminder that he needs to finish off
vegeta as soon as possible and he does
get a hit in that breaks through
vegeta's armor and hurts him it hurts
him enough to have vegeta transform
back to his base form my dude is choking
up blood and yet he's laughing
saying what fun this feeling it's been
ages there's no planet to protect
no people to save just me immersed in
battle
my happy place just the thing to get a
battle crazed saiyan's blood pumping we
see vegeta's face
he's clearly in immense pain and yet
he's clearly also loving it
my god this is epic and it's vegeta at
his best
honestly if the chapter ended here it
would have been one of my favorite super
chapters already
but it's not over vegeta goes on to
unleash even more power
and what we can assume is god of
destruction aura surrounds him
sending granola flying back goku even
says his ki feels like god ki
but not just any old god ki implying
that he has in fact reached a sort of
more perfected god of destruction state
granola is actually scared now as his
blasts can't even penetrate vegeta's god
ki
granola is sweating in shock when he
finally sees vegeta through the aura and
then we see it too
vegeta's new form and i'm so happy we
got it
he has the super saiyan 3 eyebrowless
face and in my opinion it works
we'll see what the hair color turns out
to be but purple would be pretty perfect
since it is the color of royalty and we
all know vegeta is the prince of all
saiyans
again it could have ended there but we
get one final page showing off the new
form even more
he appears completely fine now doesn't
appear to be in any pain so the form did
appear to heal him as well
another cool aspect of it he then says
and i quote a god of destruction taught
me that power derived solely from
instinct is unbounded end quote so we'll
see how this statement
exactly gets expanded upon from here but
it definitely solidifies this form as an
answer to goku's mastered ultra instinct
and i could not be happier i feel like
vegeta has to have moved ahead of goku
with this transformation yes master
ultra instant goku was caught off guard
by non-clone granola's attack
and it doesn't mean that super saiyan
blue vegeta was stronger than him just
because he lasted longer in a fight with
granola but with this transformation
i can't see vegeta not being ahead of
goku now even if only temporarily
and i absolutely love that this is what
i really love about dragon ball super
the fact
that vegeta hasn't fallen behind and can
even have amazing mind-blowing moments
of his
own where he unlocks his own op form
like in this chapter i don't know if my
hype for vegeta has ever been greater
than right now and that's an
accomplishment
in and of itself so thank you dragon
ball super overall
like i said i absolutely love this
chapter and i can't remember last time i
was this excited for the next dragon
ball super chapter to come out let me
know what you thought of this chapter in
the comments do you like the new form
and how do you think vegeta currently
measures up to goku
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming you know what to do
channel the god of destruction within
and smash that like button until it's
blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball super videos
also while you wait for the next dragon
ball super chapter to drop
feel free to check out my dragon ball
version podcast where i watch the entire
dragon ball series from beginning to end
with my friend who's never watched anime
before and we discuss it
we're already on the morrow arc so we'll
get to the granola arc
very soon link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube
who helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost i want to
thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord wigo
himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grata but they have the al-jatal
hinokami and water
the toasted she the spike eight two two
seven emperor otaku spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkis
fake buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh the red-haired raven
angel crews rathu and deiora
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted no ted fatboy games
corey mcgowan and soul rise slice and
dice thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar or you can
become a channel member here on youtube
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested and as i mentioned you
can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way
if you prefer whichever way to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you